[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez imaginez un salon c'est le soir
une télé qui diffuse un dessin animé en
noir et blanc
nous sommes dans les années 60 c'est un
vieux film d'emile cohl
une petite fille de quatre ans est
assise elle regarde la télé une main sur
un écran noir dessine un personnage avec
des traits blancs le geste de la main et
fluide et à chaque dessin le personnage
s'anime quelque chose de particulier se
passe ce soir là la petite fille est
captivé sa concentration maximale ce
qu'elle voit c'est du ressort de la
magie un espace dans lequel le dessin
deviendrait réalité un espace dans
lequel le dessin prendrait vit un tel
espace peut-il vraiment existé et si
c'était le cas comment faire pour que le
dessin soit juste que le dessin soit si
réussie gagnerait le droit d'exister
dans le réel
il s'est passé quelque chose qu'elle ne
comprenait pas mais c'était une évidence
elle serait cette main qui dessinent et
que ce serait par le dessin qu'elle
réalisera ses rêves et par là même se
réaliserait cette petite fille c'était
moi
depuis ce jour je n'ai jamais cessé de
dessiner je regardais tout ce qui
m'entourait jeu le captur est je le
saisis c'est je le restituer
je voulais créer mon monde et puis je me
suis rendu compte assez rapidement que
le dessin n'était pas considérée comme
une chose très sérieuse
j'emmenais même culpabilisés par moments
lorsque je dessinais jusqu'à une
rencontre avec mon professeur de dessin
en classe de 6ème en constatant lusage
très intensif que je faisais des
pochettes quand son quart raisin elle
m'a invité chez elle
je me suis senti très spécial j'entrais
dans son atelier totalement inconnu et
pourtant si immédiatement famille et
elle me présente un grand panneau vierge
de dessin un panneau immense immense en
fin de compte c'est l'effet qu'il m'a
fait je n'avait que 11 ans c'était un
format univers est là elle m'a dit elle
va zy exprime toi et elle m'a planté là
je faisais face à l'infini l'infini des
possibles je ressentais un sentiment à
la fois d'excitation et d'angoise parce
que c'était une évidence je ne savais
vraiment pas comment m'y prendre
et c'était paralysant
je n'avais aucune notion technique
comment allait se faire pour représenter
ses idées j'avais dans la tête je
n'allais pas faire marche arrière
j'étais venu jusque là je me suis lancé
je me suis mise à projeter ce que
j'avais dans la tête sur le panneau je
les couverts sans limite et là
j'ai compris la clé c'était de faire
sans se poser de questions sans chercher
à maîtriser la technique juste d'être ce
que je faisais et l' extraordinaire tout
ce qu'il y avait autour de moi a disparu
j'étais ce que je faisais j'étais
immergé dans le monde est possible et
c'était beau depuis ce jour j'ai su que
rien ne serait assez beau assez grand
assez fou
cette permission de dessiner que m'a
offerte au professeur de dessin au
collège mais enfin libérée d'une chose
une chose essentielle c'est que le
dessin ce n'est pas difficile
elle m'a libéré du fait que le dessin
c'était bien faire parce que en fin de
compte le dessin c'est quoi qu'est ce
que le dessin le dessin c'est
fondamentalement trois choses de
l'observation de l'intériorisation et la
restitution observations intériorisation
restitution on commence par observer ce
qui nous entoure
c'est l'observation puis l'on porte ce
que nous on a observé en nous on le
nourrit de nos expériences personnelles
de nos imaginaires
ça c'est la phrase d'intériorisation et
puis on exprime hors de nous avec des
lignes des couleurs des formes et ça
c'est la restitution et ça on le fait en
font naturellement
regardez l'enfant qui dessine
il regarde ce qui l'entourent pour le
comprendre pour le saisir pour le
modifier
comme lorsqu'il jette une pierre dans
l'eau et qu'ils observent les effets
ondulatoire pour se sentir exister
ils vont à l'essentiel
il voit comme il ressent il voit en 3d
et la restitution en 2d sur le papier
n'est pas un problème
il dessine dans l'intuition il
représente son monde à sa façon c'est de
cet aller-retour qu'il tire le plaisir
de dessiner
alors pourquoi six enfants dessinée est
un tel plaisir
[Musique]
cessons nous dessiner à l'âge adulte
alors on grandit on vieillit et on va à
l'école
et là les choses sérieuses arrivent
elles arrivent lorsque l'enfant cherche
à communiquer à se faire comprendre
auprès des adultes car pour se faire
comprendre en a besoin de repères de
reconnaissance et dans les itérations
avec ses échanges avec les adultes
enfants on se rend compte assez vite
qu'il y a une bonne façon de faire on
intègre jusque j'appellerais la notion
d'efficacité on reproduit
on fait comme tout le monde et le beau
soleil aux tentacules verte qui couvrait
la page devient un quart de rond jaune
en haut à droite
encouragés par les adultes
la technique devient progressivement un
savoir faire quelque chose qui tue
d'intuition l'originalité on regarde et
on apprend maintenant le monde parlait
savoir l'anatomie leçon de choses
la physique l'abstraction et alors on
oublie tout on ne sait plus restituer
comme on le faisait quand on était
enfant on restitue un code est là un
constat simple c'est que plus
l'observation l'intériorisation et la
restitution de ce que l'on a représenté
se complexifie par l'accumulation de
savoir plus la technique pour y parvenir
devient insurmontable à moins d'y
consacrer bien sûr tout son temps toute
son énergie
voir toute sa vie et c'est pour cela que
l'on arrête de dessiner et c'est pour
cela que vous avez arrêté de dessiner le
dessin est devenu un ordre une
instruction une discipline un acte de
spécialistes pénible et difficile dans
son apprentissage il est d'ailleurs très
couramment utilisé des mots comme rendu
exécution ce sont les thèmes que nous
utilisons nous les designers je crois
que ce sont des termes qui exprime assez
bien ce que je des seuils de vous faire
comprendre
et cette particularité qui est ce
processus itératif expérimental qui est
le coeur du dessin est réduit à des
savoir faire technique des savoir faire
technique qui pour la plupart ont
toujours tenté de restituer la 3d en 2d
pour les citer la perspective les plans
les espaces et aux normes et jusqu'à la
3d numérique
ils ont été autant de manifestations
dans l'histoire de la tentative de
trouver ce langage universel de façon à
communiquer avec le dessin et figurez
vous que ce code que nous utilisons
encore aujourd'hui lorsque nous
dessinons en 2d n'a pas évolué depuis
16e siècle nous appréhendons le monde en
3d avec nos sens
la maîtrise pourtant de la technique
peut devenir à un moment donné du
plaisir
pour le dire autrement lorsque la
technique redevient un moyen maîtriser
et à ce moment là il devient le vecteur
d'une quête le terrain de jeu de d'une
expression de la créativité dans mon cas
je ne peux même pas m'imaginer penser
sans dessiner le dessin le croquis le
schéma quelles que soient les formes de
dessins sont autant de processus de
pensée en ce qui me concerne
parce que ce n'a rien à voir avec le
fait que je suis designer savoir avec
une seule chose c'est que je bouge quand
je dessine ma main bouge
nietzsche disait qu'il pensait mieux
lorsqu'il marchait pas ce qu'on engage
son corps donc tous appréhendons le
monde en 3d et donc on peut se demander
la recherche fondamentale c'est
éventuellement d'essayer de le restituer
en 3d là où surgissent nos imaginaires
ils surgissent en 3d et constat encore
une fois si vous prenez le papier le
tableau nos écrans qu'ils soient tous
petits qu'ils soient très grands sont
tous des surfaces planes
on pense en 3d on interagit en 2d donc
pour imaginer nos villes nos maisons nos
véhicules
nos préférences de vie vous imaginez
bien que la quête ultime c'est de penser
en 3d et d'avoir une restitution en 3d
c'est cette quête qui a animé énormément
d'artistes
ils ont cherché à déconstruire cette
convention du 16e siècle à casser le
code pour cela ils n'avaient que le
collage la peinture pour représenter le
modèle en 3d
picasso on voulait aller plus loin il a
inventé un style et lumineux qui lorsqu
il dessinait capture est la trace de sa
pensée par l'instantané de la photo
picasso challenge et la technique comme
les designers aujourd'hui nous changelog
technique parce que ce que nous avons à
représenter et toujours plus grand que
ce que la technique nous permet donc je
travaille actuellement avec une équipe
de designers et de développeurs une
équipe pluridisciplinaire et nous
partageons un rêve celui de rendre le
dessin accessible à tous et en même
temps de le vivre en 3d
ce que je vais vous présenter maintenant
c'est la recherche qui a abouti à ce
dispositif que je vais avoir la vraiment
la chance de vous présenter en live
je suis dans un monde 3d dans lequel je
vais dessiner pour vous
[Musique]
je vais dessiner pour vous
un cheval
[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le constater
je sens je sais que c'est un cheval mais
je vis ce dessin je le construis
paraîtrait
il est comme il est
et le plaisir que je tire à dessiner il
est du fait de dessiner
[Musique]
et alors ce qui est merveilleux voyez
c'est que j'ai un dessin en 3d vous vous
souvenez de la petite fille ou souvenez
de la petite fille la main qui dessine
[Musique]
et la vie qui surgit
je vais faire une petite cuillère
deux feux
[Musique]
le cube
et voilà je pourrais rester des heures
dans cet espace
mais je crois que vous mmes attendez je
vais quand même assuré que cheval ne
s'échappe pas donc je vais lui faire des
reines
je vais bien évidemment raccrocher à mes
mains
n'envoyez le rêve de cette petite fille
est devenue réalité
ce dessin cet espace cette technologie
est aujourd'hui disponible
je suis presque sûr que vous serez
encourager à l'utiliser
je suis designer je travaille à la
frontière entre l'art et la technique et
je crois que mon rôle c'est d'être à la
médiation entre les technologies et la
création des usages souhaitable
pertinents comme de créer de réaliser
des dispositifs qui vont vous permettre
à vous tous d'aller plus loin de faire
en sorte que la technique ne soit plus
jamais un problème j'ai pris les armes
pour votre plaisir à tous si vous
considérez que vous n'avez plus besoin
maintenant parité de dessiner si vous
pouvez imaginer dessiner le monde que
vous aimez
retrouvez votre âme d'enfant je vous le
demande
à quel âge allez vous recommencez à
dessiner merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]